>>> UKRAINE PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY
SAYS HE'S HEADING HOME WITH GOOD
RESULTS AFTER WHIRLWIND DAY IN
WASHINGTON.
>> Translator: I THANK PRESIDENT
BIDEN FOR HIS ASSISTANT AND
INTERNATIONAL LEADERSHIP AND HIS
COMMITMENT TO VICTORY.
I THANK THE U.S. CONGRESS TO
BOTH HOUSES TO ALL PARTIES THAT
SUPPORT UKRAINE, TO ALL THOSE
WHO WISH US VICTORY AS MUCH AS
WE WISH IT.
THE VICTORY WILL COME.
>> ONE OF THOSE GOOD RESULTS,
$1.8 BILLION PACKAGE FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE INCLUDING THAT
PATRIOT SURFACE-TO-AIR MISSILE
SYSTEM.
THE PENTAGON SAYS IT WILL START
TRAINING UKRAINIAN SOLDIERS TO
USE THE SYSTEM VERY SOON.
NOW, THE KREMLIN IS NOT PLEASED
WITH THAT.
SPOKESPERSON DMITRY PESKOV
ROTE -- THE WEAPONS SUPPLIED TO
UKRAINE DOES NOT CONTRIBUTE TO A
SPEEDY SETTLEMENT OF THE
SITUATION.
ON THE CONTRARY LEADS TO THE
FACT SUFFERING OF THE UKRAINE
PEOPLE WILL CONTINUE LONGER THAN
IT COULD HAVE.
LET'S DISCUSS WITH CNN
COMMENTATOR AND FORMER MOSCOW
BUREAU CHIEF JILL DOUGHERTY.
DID TO SEE YOU.
THE RUSSIAN RESPONSE TO THE
VISIT AND THE NEW MISSILE SYSTEM
IS BOTH MUSCULAR, WHERE THEY
SAY, WE ARE GOING TO INVEST IN
NEW WEAPONRY, WE'RE GOING TO
INCREASE THE MILITARY BY 50%,
AND THEN ON THE OTHER SIDE THIS
KIND OF WHINEY, THEY DIDN'T TALK
ABOUT WHAT WE WANT WHILE THEY
WERE THERE.
PUT INTO CONTEXT THIS RESPONSE
WE'RE SEEING FROM RUSSIA.
>> Reporter: YEAH.
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT,
VICTOR.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
THE DAY THAT ZELENSKYY WAS HERE,
PUTIN MEETING WITH HIS DEFENSE
MINISTER, TALKING ABOUT REALLY
MAJOR REINVESTMENT IN THE
MILITARY, REORGANIZING IT,
INCREASING THE NUMBERS.
NEW HYPERSONIC MISSILES, AND, IN
FACT, EVEN PRESIDENT PUTIN
HIMSELF SAID WE NEED MORE DRONES
AND WE HAVE TO PUT THEM
EVERYWHERE.
SO THERE WAS A BIG EMPHASIS ON
THAT, AND THEN ALSO I THINK IN
THAT KIND OF MUSCULAR MESSAGING
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT, PRESIDENT
PUTIN WAS SAYING, YOU KNOW, THIS
IS A CONFLICT WITH NATO.
AND WE CAN ANSWER NATO.
WE CAN FIND ANYWHERE.
WE CAN PUT AS MUCH MONEY AS IS
NECESSARY INTO THIS, AND THEN HE
EVEN ADDED, YOU KNOW, WAR IS
TOUGH.
PEOPLE DIE.
IT'S REALLY TOO BAD, BUT BETTER
NOW THAN LATER, AND THEN THE
OTHER WHINEY SIDE WAS, I THINK
YOU KNOW, IF YOU WERE PRESIDENT
PUTIN, I THINK YOU'D HAVE TO BE
KIND OF -- I DON'T KNOW -- HURT
BY THE FACT THAT THERE IS
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY ON THE WORLD
STAGE, MEETING WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
AND THE IMAGERY COMING FROM THE
KREMLIN WAS, PRESIDENT PUTIN IN
THE KREMLIN BEHIND, YOU KNOW, IN
A SUIT BEHIND A PODIUM, A VERY
KIND OF OLD IMAGE OF A LEADER,
WHEREAS ZELENSKYY IS THERE, YOU
KNOW, IN HIS FATIGUES IN THAT
OLIVE DRAB LOOKING VERY MUCH
LIKE A WARTIME LEADER.
VERY DIFFERENT PICTURES.
>> YEAH.
NOT AS ROBUST IMAGE OF PRESIDENT
PUTIN PRESIDENT PUTIN.
LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT THE PATRIOT
MISSILE SYSTEM HERE.
EVERY INSTALLMENT OF -- OF
MILITARY SUPPORT FROM THE WEST,
FROM THE U.S., COMES WITH THIS
THREAT FROM RUSSIA.
SOMETIMES IT'S NUCLEAR.
SOMETIMES NOT.
I WONDER HOW THEY SEE THE
ADDITION OF THIS PATRIOT MISSILE
SYSTEM?
OF COURSE, UKRAINES THINK THIS
IS A STEP FORWARD.
HOW ESCALATORY DO THE RUSSIANS
BELIEVE IT IS?
>> Reporter: WELL, I MEAN, LET'S
LOOK AT WHAT PRESIDENT PUTIN
SAID TODAY.
HE SAID, YEAH, IT'S AN OLD
SYSTEM, AND WE CAN KNOCK IT
DOWN.
SO HE'S REALLY, YOU KNOW,
DISMISSING IT.
HE SAID THAT IT'S NOT AS GOOD AS
OUR S-300s.
SO I THINK, THAT'S HIS RESPONSE,
KIND OF DISMISSING IT.
WHAT MILITARILY THEY THINK, I'M
SURE IS THAT IT IS A POTENT
SYSTEM.
GRANTED, THERE'S ONLY ONE
BATTERY AT THIS POINT, BUT I
THINK SYMBOLICALLY, AND THAT'S,
YOU KNOW, WE'RE TALKING
MILITARY, BUT ALSO SYMBOLISM, IT
IS A SIGN OF THE ESCALATION OF
THE AID COMING FROM THE UNITED
STATES MILITARILY FOR UKRAINE.
SO I WOULD PRESUME THAT MOSCOW
WOULD BE WORRIED ABOUT THAT, AND
HENCE, THAT'S WHY YOU HAVE THE
KREMLIN SAYING, WELL, THIS IS
JUST GOING TO CREATE MORE
PROBLEMS AND MORE SUFFERING.
I THINK ALL THE MESSAGE, VICTOR,
COMING FROM MOSCOW IS, THIS IS
GOING TO GO ON FOR A VERY, VERY
LONG TIME, AND I WOULD SAY THAT
PUTIN HAS REALLY UPPED T